[Musique]
pourquoi le zèbre a-til cette
apparence
concrezv différ
maintenant j'ai beaucoup pensé à toi ces
derniers temps c'est que tuar dans tous
mes rêves tu fais rien tu es juste là
donc c'est plutôt une personne précise
un Mo que rien
remarablei vécu cette expérience as-tu
sa
[Musique]
photo est-ce que par hasard tu as rêvé
de moi si j'ai rêvé de toi c'est ce que
tu me demandes
ou une centaine de messages y quelqu'un
qui veut m'interviewer c'est étrange tu
devrais peutêre t'arrêter une minute
avant de faire quelque chose de
drastique pourquoi
moi j'en sais rien je suis peut-être
spécial
qu'est-ce que ça fait de devenir viral
qui d'entre vous est certain d'avoir
rêvé de
[Musique]
moi vous êtes l'homme des cauchemars
c'est totalement co moi j'aimerais bien
que les gens rêvent de moi et moi donc
ouais non c'est quelque chose c'est très
spécial quelle réaction il a face à tout
ça on est loin d'être des personnes qui
aiment bien attirer l'attention tu crois
que d'autres personnes te voient nu des
milliers peut-être
j'espère que je me comporte bien non
c'est loin d'être le cas finalement je
suis cool c'est pas ce que j'ai dit non
bien dire que je suis un père
cou j'ai vraiment l'impression que tu
joues avec le
feu PAP ai c'est pas la réalité de le
fait aucun
mal être célèbre s'accompagne d' fa
secondaires indésirable vous devez être
prêt à faire face à cela on devrait
peut-être calmer les choses quoi de quoi
tu parles c'est embarrassant quelle
[Musique]
partie en tout cas je suppose que je te
verrai dans mes rêves oui bien sûr que
non
[Musique]
merci